in this video you will learn to process
the information in your mind in a
completely different way from the
reality you experience daily when you
are awake
Neuroscience has discovered that what we
experience in our dreams is simply a
more exciting and a logical
interpretation of the information
already present in our brain and the
technique we are going to discuss today
will teach you how to control the
manifestation of your dreams so that you
can find the solution you are looking
for
it is a tool that has been used by the
best scientists in the world Nikola
Tesla Albert Einstein Thomas Edison and
Richard Feynman used it to solve the
most complex problems and visualize new
scientific theories award-winning
directors like Christopher Nolan and
James Cameron have used this technique
during the creative process for their
movies in fact the film Inception was
based on Christopher Nolan's personal
experience notably famous surrealist
painter Salvador Dali used the lucid
dream technique long before it had been
scientifically verified specifically
Salvador Dali practiced dream incubation
to pre-program his dreams and this was
the secret behind many of his pieces
that were actually based on his dreams
an example was the dream prompted by a
bee flying around a pomegranate a second
before he awoke so what are lucid dreams
and what can they be used for
[Music]
lucid dreams are dreams in which the
sleeper is aware that he or she is
dreaming during lucid dreams the dreamer
can acquire a certain control over him
or herself other participants the story
and the surroundings for example if you
don't feel like running away from a
killer in the street you can actually
change the narrative and instead of
running you can decide to speak to the
Killer and discover that it isn't a
killer at all but a person trying to
return the wallet that you had lost
you can completely change the story and
venture to a different area of your
subconscious with brand new characters
and themes you are the one deciding
where to go and what to do now that the
subconscious is Again part of the
collective discussion practicing the
lucid dream technique has become easier
lucid dreamers can use certain tricks to
influence their brain to dream about a
specific problem and solve it or to
dream and develop a new idea lucid
dreamers are able to train their minds
to work towards their goals even while
they sleep such as improving their
confidence or athletic abilities lucid
dreamers are also able to open their
minds to become more creative exploring
the dreams they experience thus taking
control and making active decisions
within the dreams rather than passively
experiencing them
they can establish Creative Connections
and test how things are working every
day we receive countless stimulations we
obviously can't process everything in
real time because we wouldn't be able to
do anything else and therefore most of
our indirect experiences are stored in
our subconscious we download a lot into
this mysterious inner world this doesn't
mean that it is just an emotional dump
on the contrary it is a sacred place
where we hide some of the memories that
have most changed our lives powerful
emotions and creative thoughts all exist
within this environment and access to
the world of your dreams is actually the
key to your actual reality lucid dreams
can help you open different doors so
here is how to implement the lucid dream
technique
do some basic preparation keep your room
clean and organized make sure that no
light enters the room from any computer
screen window Etc make your room as dark
as possible at this point we should
mention that when you go to sleep this
method will cause you to wake up a
little bit sooner than normal for just a
few seconds it is literally only to wake
your mind up don't worry you won't need
to get out of bed this method is called
Awakening technique and as the name
suggests it consists of setting an alarm
clock to wake our mind up and then go
back to sleep there are excellent
reasons for this your brain is more
active during REM sleep REM which stands
for rapid eye movement is an event that
takes place a couple of hours before
your natural Awakening as a first step
you must think about lucid dreams for
the entire day write read and talk to
your friends about what you intend to do
in your lucid dream the key is
concentrating on what you intend to do
then you must practice assessing reality
to verify whether you are awake or
dreaming you must perform these checks
about 10 times a day but if you want to
have a lucid dream tonight execute at
least 25 of These reality tests before
going to bed the most effective test to
assess whether you are dreaming is this
open up your hand and try to stick your
finger into your palm expect for the
finger to go through and when it doesn't
state to yourself I must be awake as if
you were convinced that the finger
should have gone through ask yourself if
you are in a dream in a dream the finger
would always go through your hand but in
real life it never will perform this
test numerous times during the day and
in the end it will happen in your dream
at that point your finger will go
through your palm and you will say to
yourself I am dreaming and you will
realize that you are actually Lucid
there are many different tests you can
do but we have learned that this one is
the most effective one the next step is
turning off all screens an hour before
bedtime and not looking at your phone
before going to bed set your phone on
vibrate mode but make sure that the
alarm still works and don't watch TV
this is because you want your body to
produce enough of the hormones that
regulate sleep and these hormones are
affected and slowed down by artificial
light therefore if you can turn off the
lights and relax a bit otherwise read a
book for about an hour before going to
bed this will start a process of
relaxation of the mind you can also wear
a sleep mask and try try to meditate the
fourth step is setting the alarm clock
at a specific time set your alarm clock
about two hours before the time you
normally wake up if you normally wake up
at 9am set the alarm for 7 am select an
alarm sound that can actually wake you
up but at the same time not too loud you
want something relaxing easy to listen
to and remember to keep your phone close
enough to you to be able to turn it off
without having to get out of bed and
opening your eyes whatever alarm you
choose select music with a soft sound or
a relaxing tone and make sure that it
will go off on time you want it to ring
and wake you up once and then turn off
make sure you keep a diary and working
pen Within Reach for drawing your dreams
so that you don't have to get out of bed
the next step is waking up with your
eyes closed you must wake up without
opening your eyes keep your eyes closed
because this will awake your mind always
remember to keep your eyes closed it
won't make a huge difference if you open
them just for a second or so but it's
better not to do it you basically want
to be able to go back to sleep as soon
as you turn off the alarm clock this is
why it is called wake back to bed you in
fact literally wake up for just a second
and then go back to to sleep there is
however one extremely important thing to
remember this Final Phase for lucid
dreaming is the most important one
because you will have a lucid dream
induced by waking up that will be a
combination of the wake back to bed
technique and induced Awakening you will
in fact wake up early thus activating
your brain but you will also go back to
sleep this is why we asked you to
perform numerous reality checks if you
accidentally fall back into deep sleep
you will hopefully assess reality in
your own dream and will become Lucid it
is a sort of safety device now the main
part of this method is what happens
after you briefly wake up you have
turned off the alarm and now you are
awake with your eyes closed then you
will remain awake in your mind but you
will let your body fall asleep this
might actually be terrifying for you if
you have never done it before because
you will experience what is known as
sleep paralysis in which your body is
not able to move however your mind is
awake and self-aware you will basically
feel your body fall asleep all while
your mind is fully aware don't worry
there is nothing to be afraid of it is
not dangerous at all this is the way in
which you can have lucid dreams tonight
at first it might seem strange and
terrifying just relax and try not to
move after doing it a couple of times it
will become easy and fun therefore as we
already mentioned you will stay awake
but your body will be frozen the reason
is that your sleep was interrupted
during the REM phase causing your body
to go into overdrive trying to go back
to a state of Deep Sleep however the key
here is to stay awake while this is
happening you will remain concentrated
and able to think while your body is
shutting down and that is what allows
you to enter directly into a lucid dream
from the very beginning because with
this method your mind never sleeps now
relax and let yourself Drift Away into
what is described as hallucinations you
will see colors shapes flashes of random
Landscapes and people at first you might
even hear sounds that will be random and
not fully formed but as you'll start
exploring them they will begin to
interconnect and last longer than just a
few seconds you will soon be so deeply
involved that you'll actually be able to
look around and that's what it is you
will be in a lucid dream and will be
able to fully control it here are a few
things to remember about dreams
especially if you were doing it for the
first time don't get too excited or you
will wake up too quickly you need to
relax and guide the dream rather than
control it at first just explore it if
you get too excited you will wake up
therefore enjoy the process just like
for everything else you will not become
a master of this technique on your first
time you will need discipline patience
and practice so tonight try to have a
lucid dream and experience information
in a new way